را
[موسيقى]
هرا بوتين يباغت الامريكان ويظهر في ساحه
المعركه الاوكرانيه والمخابرات الامريكيه
يجب على الجنرالات الاوكراني قاله
زيلينسكي لايقاف الصراع وخلاف نووي روسي
ياباني الكيان يستعيد الاف القذائف التي
ارسلها لكييف ويطلب المزيد من المسيرات
الامريكيه تقرير يكشف تحذير البيت الابيض
من غضب عربي تجاه الولايات المتحده
وواشنطن تخشى معركه وشيكه مع الصين وقطر
تحذر الجيش العبري من امر خطير في
القطاع تل ابيب تطلب المسيرات
بشراها الصوارخ لا تكفي وضربات الطائرات
لم تحقق اهدافها حتى الاسلحه في البحر لم
تكن كافيه للجيش العبري ليكشف تقرير
لصحيفه ول ستريت جورنال عن زياده لافته في
طلبي تلبيب للطائرات المسيره من السوق
الامريكي منذ اندلاع الحرب ياتي التقرير
غداه اعلان الجيش العبري البداء باستخدام
طائرات مسيره من نوع نيت سوب في القطاع
والتي كان استلامها قبل اسابيع فقط ليس
ذلك فحسب بل اكدت صحيفه يديع تحر نوت
العبريه ان سفينه امريكيه انهت تفريغ
عشرات الالاف من القذائف من عيار 155 ملر
التي كانت قد ارسلت لكيف وتم استعادتها
وارسالها الى الكيان لاستخدامه في
المواجهات مع الفصائل فيما قال النتنياهو
لقناه فوكس نيوز ان الهجوم الجويه والبريه
الاسرائيليه المستمر اكثر من شهر ضد
الفصائل استغرق وقتا اطول مما كان يامل
وفي المواقف الدوليه اكد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن الحاجه الى بذل
المزيد لحمايه المدنيين في القطاع مضيفا
انه قد خسر عدد كبير جدا من المدنيين
حياتهم ونريد منع الحاق الضرر بالعديد ممن
عانوا في الاسابيع الماضيه وزياده
المساعدات التي تصل لهم الى اقصى حد هناك
حذرت وزاره الخارجيه القطريه من نيه الجيش
العبري الواضحه لتكرير ما ارتكبه في
المستشفى المعمدان في مجمع الشفاء الطبي
غرب القطاع وطلبت المجتمع الدولي بالتدخل
العاجل لتوفير الحمايه لمجمع الشفاء الطبي
ومن فيه وسط اشتباكات وحصار عبري له
بالعوده الى مشافي القطاع افادت قناه الغد
بان دبابات الكيان قد وصلت الى محيط
مستشفيات الرنتيسي والنصر والعيون في
القطاع ياتي ذلك في ظل تعرض محيط
المستشفيات الثلاثه للقصف من قبل الكيان
مع مناشدات للمؤسسات الدوليه للتدخل لح
حمايه المرضى والاطفال والنازحين بعيدا عن
لهيب المواجهات حذر الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب من ان الرئيس الحالي
جو بايدن من خلال تصرفاته قد يقود العالم
الى حرب عالميه ثالثه وصراع نووي لازلنا
في امريكا حيث حذر دبلوماسيون امريكيون
البيت الابيض من ان الولايات المتحده تفقد
ثقه العالم العربي بسبب الدعم النشط
للعمليه العبريه تحذيرات الدبلوماسيين
جاءت من خلال برقيه تم ارسالها من سفاره
الولايات المتحده في سلطنه عمان الى مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي ووكاله المخابرات
المركزيه ومكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
واشنطن تتحدث ايضا عن خططها ونقل متحدث
رفيع المستوى في الاداره الامريكيه ان
الولايات المتحده لا تبحث عن صراع مع
الصين ولا تنوي الدخول في حرب بارده جديده
معها وتاتي هذه التصريحات قبيل القمه
المرتقبه للرئيسين الامريكي جو بايدن
والصيني شيجين بين في سان فرانسيسكو
المقرره خلال الايام
المقبله بوتين في ارض
المعركه بعيدا عن الاعين الغربيه موسكو
عازمه على تحقيق اهدافها في اوكرانيا هنا
قام الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بزياره
مفاجئه الى المقر العام للجيش الروسي الذي
يشرف على العمليه في اوكرانيا في روستو
فوندون بحسب ما اعلن الكرملين ورافق
الرئيس الروسي خلال هذه الرحله وزير
الدفاع سيرجي شاجو ورئيس الاركان وقائد
العمليات العسكريه في اوكرانيا بليري زيمو
منن خطط جديده للدب الروسي في المقابل
افادت بلومبرج بان الاتحاد الاوروبي اخطر
الدول الاعضاء بانه من غير المرجح ان يفي
بوعده بتزويد كيف بمليون قذيفه بحلول مارس
2024 فيما صرح ضابط المخابرات العسكريه
الامريكيه السابق سكوت ريتر لقناه ريبور
تي في ميديا انه يجب على الجنرالات
الاوكرانيين اقاله الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديمير زيلينسكي من اجل وقف الصراع في
البلاد والحفاظ على الاراضي المتبقيه في
كيب من جانب اخر افادت صحيفه اتلانتك
الامريكيه انهم في الغرب يعتقدون بامكانيه
حل الصراع في اوكرانيا وفقا للسيناريو
الكوري وسيتم تجميد الحدود على خط
المواجهه الحالي وحمايه بقيه اوكرانيا مثل
كوريا الجنوبيه بضمانات امنيه امريكيه
وحتى قواعد امريكيه في الميدان افادت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بان ق مجموعه المركز
التابعه للقوات المسلحه الروسيه على اتجاه
كرسن ليمان صدت تسع هجمات معاديه خلال
اسبوع
وحيدتي و444 وحده من المعدات التابعه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه حسب سبوتنيك
ليفيد مركز المخابرات التابع لقوات الدفاع
الاستونيه في بيان ان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه وصلت هذا الاسبوع الهجوم بكثافه
متزايده واخذت زما امام المبادره في
المعارك الرئيسيه على قسمين من الجبهه على
خط افدي اف كا مارينكا في جمهوريه دونتسك
الشعبيه وخط كوبيانسك س فوفو في جمهوريه
لوغانسك الشعبيه لتنتقل بنا الاحداث الى
اليابان حيث علقت روسيا العمل باتفاقيه مع
اليابان لوقف استخدام اسلحه نوويه واظهرت
وثيقه حكوميه نشرت على البوابه
الالكترونيه الرسميه للحكومه الروسيه ان
رئيس الوزراء الروسي ميخائيل موستن وقع
على امر بتعليق الاتفاقيه المبرمه عام 93
ولم تذكر موسكو سببا لهذا القرار لكنها
قالت ان وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ستبلغ
اليابان بهذه
[موسيقى]
الخطوه